in a way I've been really thinking a lot
in a Microsoft and how to design a
conversational AI systems you know Catan
just one of them another one I want to
bring your attention to you is actually
chatbots
so we actually shifted the first eject
button China about the three and a half
years ago it's called the showers in
China now actually she has about a
hundred million users in China and the
talking to her you know on average like
23 turns and she's actually very very
talented you know in China that she's
even hosting a TV program on e news
programming in Shanghai was over 800
million viewership and she recently
actually in a demonstrate her ability to
write poems she actually published a
poetry book you know amazing and that
helped over you know help it is the
Chinese users to write over 2 million
poems and just so you understand that
the scale the number of poems that's
more than all the poems ever published
in the history of China so that's only
in China in the in Japan and a year
later we actually launched in Japan
called arena the chat bar Reena and it's
even more popular in Japan at 25 percent
of Japanese population have already
talked at arena in Japan and she's also
now powering a chatbots in a for
Nintendo's Pokemon so and of course you
know now here right here in the United
States as you some of you might remember
exactly a year ago you know we celebrate
the arrival of zou I won't share but
here in the US you know in just a year
I'm happy to tell you that now we
actually have she actually has over a
million users
just like Xiao Weis and arena and the
zou actually has developed several AI
driven senses like voice recognition
image recognition and the social
commenting and the natural language
understanding people can now rhyme with
zou in a rap battle and it's really
amazing
our challenge her for a game of
exploding kittens or even interact with
her newest uh friend the poppy of a
popular youtuber it's just a
things that you can do with that with
the chat box but then you might have
wonder so why did you pay so much
attention to chat bus let me just say
that chit chat is characteristic of
human beings just go home and think
about this so most of us are intelligent
agents today like a serial katana focus
on tasks accomplishing or IQ getting
star with the skill chain and chaining
like what they just saw from Christina's
demo it's fabulous it's really helping
get things done but it is the emotional
intelligence or the EQ that enables
sustain the conversations at dialogues
which you will be critical to truly
understand the human users so by
engaging with the people you know much
more social and the personal level in
our chat buzz now I develop in their EQ
so learning how to react responds and
based on the data that from those human
interaction so then we can take those
learnings and apply them to many other
products so of course you know you
Microsoft not only you know we do those
conversational AI products you know we
also make sure that our AI investments
you know will be infused into all
Microsoft products and services that
drive deeper and the more personal
experiences the first place we start of
course will be windows you know windows
is already using machine learning and
the computer vision for example to help
you to personalize your photos and
videos it's really amazing if you think
about it the explosion of digital photos
on average for a Windows user in every
year the user would take 52 thousand
photos there's no way you can keep track
of so many photos and do something you
know with those photos until now with
the help of AI let's roll the video and
show you what we have been doing with
Windows filled photo in the video
today we capture more photos and videos
than ever before in history and we are
building a suite of AI driven tools
within Microsoft photos to transform the
way the next generation of Windows users
dreams captures and expresses themselves
this month we shipped a brand new search
system that uses machine learning to let
you find people places and things in
your photos to give you a starting point
for creating videos we have created
systems that automatically generate
movies from your media special effects
are some of the most coveted features by
our Gen Z audience so we are using
computer vision and AI to track objects
in your videos just inka doodle anchor
it and watch it follow something in the
video we are excited to be bringing
differentiated experiences based on AI
and machine learning to over 250 million
devices every month everything is going
to become more intelligence as you think
about that you know managing of IO is
creating and you know all those things